i am so curious if someone has actually
never seen anything that you've done
before what is the first thing you want
them watching and why
huh that's a great question
my initial instinct is to start at the
beginning uh and and and
that would be a film called the bay boy
uh
because it's where i started and and and
everything from that point forward is an
evolution
going outside of what i would
instinctually say would probably be 24
because
that was
the time
that so much changed for me as an actor
for instance
uh when i started working as an actor uh
robert de niro who had
the biggest career at the time would do
maybe one to one and a half movies every
two years right so maybe two movies
every three years
um
and and all of the young actors thought
that that was what we were supposed to
do
now if i want to become an olympic
runner i train every day
and so when i got to do 24 i got to work
every day and so the training for me
uh
as an actor really began there because
you know we're working at such a fast
pace compared to that of making a film
um
and and so i feel
that
my my knowledge of the craft of acting
grew exponentially
during that time period so uh 24 is
kind of what i would maybe recommend
someone if they wanted to see me mature
at least as an actor
uh what was it about this particular
project that said i want to make this i
want to play this role it was a
combination of things i mean obviously
for me the script is the most important
thing that that will always be
the deciding factor of why i'm moved to
be a part of telling that story and and
this on two levels uh this script is an
it was an incredible thriller it was
exciting uh it was a page turner but it
also taught me about an area
of something that i just did not know
anything about which was
you know that there were recruiters out
there that were picking out
kind of the best of the best of the
special forces as they were either being
pushed out of the armed forces or
retiring and that they were using them
for special private ops so that they
were being hired out by corporations as
security details to do
in the context of this movie um
illegal work
that's a you know for companies to start
getting private armies
that's a very scary
opera you know option um and and
and you certainly have you know all of
us were aware of kind of the troubles
that blackwater ran into in iraq when
there are some of their uh operators uh
you know abused their authority and and
and killed civilians
uh
in the street um so it's it's
it's it it opened my eyes to uh uh
something that i just simply was not
very familiar about and so the
combination of being a great thriller
and kind of learning something at the
same time
uh
was very appealing to me as an actor
and then
you know chris pine and ben foster uh
did a movie called hell or high water
and i thought they they were one of the
best duos that i had seen since kind of
uh robert redford and paul newman um
they're the way they work together uh
is just
cool uh there's a kind of
they exploit humor uh
when there isn't any it's just innately
how they behave with each other
um
and i i was i was thrilled to be able to
do a film with them
yeah i told them when i spoke to them
that they need to make like 10 more
movies together yeah i agree
and i'll go see every one of them
uh how also were you uh happy to be able
to use your tattoos in the role
i was happy not to cover them up
exactly uh you know because that's a
long process um
you know and uh and and i've had these
tattoos for you know for years and years
and years
uh
and obviously
jack bauer did not and uh so
you know
i had to approach
wore a lot of long sleeves on very hot
days um but no every once in a while if
if it suits the character
then uh and i felt that it did with this
that that it was it was nice not to have
to cover them up before i run out of
time with you i am a big fan of dark
city
man and i've never gotten to talk to you
about it so here's that moment um when
you think back on the making of it i
love learning like the behind the scenes
like [ __ ] you don't hear in the press
notes or hear about so what are like
cool things that fans of that movie
might not realize about the making of
the movie well i'll tell you something i
mean so alex preuss had written that as
a cartoon
uh or at some cartoons not right
animated uh event he'd written it uh
when he was 15 years old he'd been
carrying that in his back pocket for a
dec decades
and and when i went to go meet with him
i met with him at a hotel in los angeles
california
my career
was kind of
treading water to put it politely um
and we were just supposed to talk about
the script but i had read it and i had
memorized parts of it already
just because i loved it so much
that i did
an impromptu we were talking having a
discussion and i said well i don't think
i can articulate it as well as i can
just show you and in the middle of the
bar of the hotel i started playing
schrieber and and with the voice and and
the walk and all of it and
i think i scared him a little bit
uh but he took a chance with me because
of my enthusiasm and i was really
grateful because it's
it's one of you know i'm very proud of
really a lot of the work i've been
you know given the opportunity to do
but dark city will always hold a special
place in my heart because i believe that
creatively it approaches what i consider
to be cinema
which is the highest art form of
filmmaking and and that was because alex
did that with it and so it was just
something i was so proud to be a part of
and uh and sadly will hurt has just
recently passed away but i think he's
extraordinary in it uh rufus sewell
jennifer um i was uh richard o'brien
just so many great actors uh and and it
was just it was a thrill to be a part of
yeah i love the movie i'm already out of
time i'm just gonna say thank you for
your work and i wish you nothing but the
best oh brother thank you i wish you
everything be safe and healthy and and i
i look forward to talking to you soon
you